okay we're gonna do one more mission
here Pierce I think this little
decorative lips that chair thing is
ready yet I don't know why we give your
whole eggs I can understand if anything
be done pretty soon I can probably head
over whenever alright see you when I get
there oh [ __ ] yeah I just getting a fine
yeah that's pretty dope think I go
through wires let's say yeah I guess I
can yeah I guess I can't huh okay let's
lower this batch let's lower this [ __ ]
I am NOT that butta butta four days you
know one Sam you know I'm saying yeah
yeah yeah ain't that nice nice you ready
to [ __ ] things up in virtual reality so
everything being shot at you can survive
a gunshot but if your mind takes too
much shock in this chair you'll go brain
dead great plan Kenzie I know you ready
let's do it thats Sarah send my tits to
the web oh great I'm great okay great
okay where we gone oh my god just trying
like I'll turn on is a sergeant you're
on what the [ __ ]
second Alice I'm a [ __ ] toilet all
right you should be seeing a visual
representation of the Decker you said
now what's with that toilet oh my god
that's me sorry about that mommy mother
of another so [ __ ] not cool sir
mature yet that was just temporary why
would you even give me this little kid
dirt link to the data I'll run it out
soon our toilet toilet great I'm a
walking sex joke lieutenant baby yeah no
guns no way to fight a lady oh good wow
this is this is better day that freaked
me out this is my way to shake his icy
fate not your [ __ ] a way
all right looks like Matt doesn't want
you punky around here you'll have to
walk your way through his defenses but
stay on fire almost all right what is
that exactly you block this come
accessing the Decker's gotta you know
when you see it okay
she says okay yeah I asked if I knows my
left hand I can't walk for a sec okay
hey Sharon dad has to be embarrassing no
anytime just like an infinite hope that
I can't get my titties organized there's
still itchy no that's not that talk that
my mother rules can change something's
wrong pin Zhi talking to watch me Audi
there you'll just have to deal I'm a
snail okay
okay snap it up [ __ ] am I know I'm
getting my my dicks suck get my dick
sucked
ok
here's that [ __ ] oh let me I'm happy
for you know how do I get past and ruin
it for you know you gotta be turns out
on your own see that's great those are
fine by me
you
ah
you
shity craftsmanship
jay says anything else I don't know [ __ ]
about huh
[ __ ] you jay says okay kid walking get
rockin pathetic childhood has just been
crushed when the rider have against
unicorns Jesus I'm not going to be
beaten by some new you've dragged into
my world kensington urban areas and
let's take a math antivirus next ok
[ __ ] toilet again
you have this Kinsey this is wanna shoot
current any contain picnic yeah so pack
in my cannon good fight we're [ __ ]
where's that
who's [ __ ] her honors
shut okay i'm packing 8 i'm back in heat
okay okay pat the ante are the cord or
something eat my body up and data okay
walking it what is that
what okay okay this anymore rocking hard
I can't tell is there like how many are
there
I can take out this this the best you
can do agent Ken Kanger be gone look a
the antivirus is all taken care of
you'll need to destroy the last edit
code have a toilet a sex doll and now a
tank just go with it
and I
he stuck a [ __ ] [ __ ] stuck god I
did it I did it ah say turn okay
okay come on create a dick in your
dreams kid oh good you're the [ __ ]
[ __ ] me coming up on the last wall
it is internet security protocols for
blocking access into the mean I don't
need to know okay okay [ __ ] it or any
more [ __ ] around for it unites the
place it's more left the night late
season 3 episode rides the sybian order
even for the Cardinal basis pant for me
you modeled this [ __ ] off of nyteblayde
it's an allegory for man's inhumanity to
man it's a shitty vampire show I don't
expect a shuttlepod like you to
appreciate you writing
okay where the other [ __ ] a lot of
pitches here okay happier charge on
pressure debug the eris can he's getting
[ __ ] up why Anzhi died he jams or just
happy fun slides right let me direct
beat into the wall well I can be imposed
to ya then step we track that sometimes
at least try lying what font tubes I
missing fun tips like I guess I'm gonna
fight this [ __ ] now I'm gonna hide this
[ __ ] Pizza they're gonna you know easy
to laugh when you're hiding like a [ __ ]
I got good come on out glad what a
[ __ ] nerd
don't you get it on god that's just fine
in the real world you're just a [ __ ]
with a keyboard
yeah you cannot beat me real world this
world it's all the same for kicking your
ass hey guys maybe you're gonna copy an
avatar look at you trying to me amusing
is it reliable
oh i thought i missed it I thought I
press the line okay you got wine when we
don't know which way is out you can
chosen that one
where is it I'll kill you one way or
another oh good yeah yeah I got this
[ __ ] what's she doing get down Oh break
them off good yeah no yeah forgot those
wings I thought you'd be faster than
this stop minding the ineligible [ __ ]
this [ __ ] cheesiest line you have oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] choke choke me and not
Oh
die
it's impossible oh yeah look at me now
we're gonna be addressed program you
should have four mean abilities afford
to me you / and birth by we can create a
giant chocolate huh dad even th fire
ratatat quick dash movie Lindsay I /
kissing right now kiss her kiss her
girls love to kiss
well it's almost quick just a [ __ ]
uses sword any when they like a hat ship
it's like not good okay okay okay I
can't you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I can
[ __ ]
Janek le sacan deckers but it's like I
don't know how you managed it agent
Kensington here comes the brat again
you're on even ground now should be beat
the case what do you think so track and
bicha graphic at his dick sucked
I can't I can't
oh my god where is he
[ __ ] nice that [ __ ] up suck it suck
the tip of my sword suck the tip my
short suckin I'll tell you and I'll tell
you what it's how to finish there's no
root beer
world time to die a callous match ok
this time I walk button a pass and I'll
finish that stretch
yeah yeah yeahs taste a suck on my
fingers you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh yeah he's all [ __ ] up hot finish
this batch hi I'm a [ __ ] and I shall
perish out session hey says giblets ha
God's got a gun how God finish him like
a man yeah yeah yeahs not optional I'm
at huh I can clear your name prove that
you didn't destroy that bridge mmm sir
Kinsey can figure it out I literally
have the world at my fingertips it's a
little vague man gotta do better you
tell me the name of a company and it
becomes the property of the Saints you
get your empire back and I get to walk
away can't huh no attacking I have a
choice what's with the doors they're
back doors into company records one door
leads to a weapons manufacturer giving
you discounts on weapon upgrades right
and this one an automotive parts
distribution house they'll discount work
done on your cars pick one and i'll get
you set up as a high priority client i
swear i need a white man's batch
I really wish you'd reconsider Maddie
these hands of mine were meant to rent
bone not hunt and peck on a keyboard
well it's typing is the issue I can
recommend some good voice recognition
software i don't know the bish you stuck
with me when i rose from Felipe's ashes
like a phoenix you and me we've bonded
that's lovely but I feel it's time for
me to move on well did it to be honest
I'm a little scared of well dying I do
run a demanding workplace Mary I
appreciate how you shared your concerns
I mean the way viola and Kiki handled
their departures made me just want to
kill someone no absolutely well I've got
a flight to catch how Maddie Oh feel
free to list me as a reference anytime
okay
oh [ __ ]
ditch out for Harambee